you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game so let's see let's try
Sicilian playing against DM j JM d
so let's see what we get I was tempted
to play e5 but that may be allowing we
may go into aroma PES well it's not
let's not play any role of heads for a
while huh after the World Championship
we've seen enough of it so I'm just
preserving the c7 square for my queen so
very beginner issue looking at first
glance to make just pawn moves and a
queen move so early but I don't think
there's any issue with declaring the
Queen straightaway made these prep moves
already e6 and a6 to stop any Knight
jumps it may even shoot for b5 right now
I have to be a little bit careful let me
get one more move in with my Kings side
I think if I go b5 there might be a
rookie one in Knight d5 sacrifice so I
want to bring it to a point where I'm
just one move away from castles so let's
get b6 and I can't get b5 in and I don't
want to allow a 5 so let's play d6 I'm
going with a small pawn Center
I don't think there's any thing wrong
with immediately committing my bishop
right now
so let's do it sometimes there could be
a concern with some pressure against e6
that the bishop was on this diagonal to
play bishop here so clearly there's this
f5 move
lined up let's play night here
and let's see how I react here to this
idea v5 hmm I should probably castle
yeah let's do it and I guess this is
going to get in okay so they're really
going up after me here is this an
opportunity for Queen c6 I wonder
hmm I think queen c6 and Bishop III
Knight g4 I don't think that that's
really working out huh all right think I
feel like I need to take some
precautions against my Kings side
not a big fan of doing this but gonna
sneak that one in there that's a very
weakening move really want to watch over
the f5 square and I think I want to now
play pawn up to e5
[Music]
I don't know let's see 'if I've
something other than a five
well this move isn't a threat just yet I
could consider Knight c5 yeah let's go
Knight c5 this truck isn't a pin also
the both king and rook are in the line
of fire same diagonal as my bishop
really chewed up a lot of time there
okay so maybe this was unnecessary I
should play Knight to c5 and rook and
reply to rook f3 only one pawn exchanged
rich middle game I couldn't still
consider a five all right well let's go
straight in for this let's get one more
piece playing this Knight is unprotected
don't know that I could take advantage
of that this bishop has a responsibility
yeah I think I might want to play e5
soon if rook g3 if I go a five there's
Knight f5 so on rook g3 I think King h8
that's interesting let's just scoot
right on by I don't want to give the b5
square up to any piece gives up c5 that
move I feel like I should just do this
anticipating okay maybe I don't want to
do that straightaway but Queen c5
let's see Queen c5 let's give it a shot
try to cause some problems with my queen
here and okay and how about Queen here
I'm on the night now 134 thought a
minute advantage I got two bishops
at any moment this night could be
challenged and they g5 mm-hmm and ig5
could be a bit annoying okay I feel like
I want to get my King here this rook is
opposite my queen and maybe now h6 you
know let's get him out of there and he
sacrifices against h6 I don't think that
that's what really working to do a push
I'd have to move my queen she does have
a square I could pick up this pawn but
not really a fan of going pawn hunting
right around this point I could also
consider age five yeah you know what I
think I might want to camp out on g5 so
I guess they're not going to woo alright
so I guess the idea is f5 my king is
gonna have to book alright let's let's
stay calm here let's take with the rook
and on this I'm gonna play g5 gonna grab
that pawn I know I know oh you know what
this nights gonna kill me I did not
appreciate the knight coming in to f5
this nights gonna kill me alright first
off my queen is under fire
you know what I'm taking that rook
yep I'm going to try and take
to the light squares III felt night
coming in at f5 would have killed me so
what's the body count here I have a rook
in a minor piece and maybe a safer King
55 seconds left I'm threatening a double
check
winning the house let's take one work
off and where the killer shots here mmm
let's start with this
King 2e1 yes
[Music]
okay hmm I just anchor my night in there
I'm going to try for that
shutting down this diagonal
Bishop c8 and I want to scoop up this
pawn what a weird imbalance
hmm all right when it take 19 seconds I
have a bishop check maybe both my
bishops can enter and at some loose
pieces
okay sixteen seconds isn't a lot either
and scoot up
hmm let's give this check
ten seconds threatening a check and then
picking up the bishop
Wow eight seconds
not a lot of time
uh-uh yeah and I'm gonna get mated I'll
have my bishop as well and now it's
falling you think I had something there
with that uh imbalance yeah it's very
tough middlegame
I think that before I look at it with
the computer I think that
if they weren't renewed for a night of
five
this point right here I think I'm
completely busted right here if they go
Knight to f5 or 93 looking at the f5
square I think I'm gonna get killed
don't know that I have anything here hmm
yeah Knight to f5
that's a dagger and a half it's
definitely some compensation there is
one way to look at it is my bishop is
just biting on a rock the e4 pawn now I
wonder what I missed
if this going in for this tactic hmm all
right let's let's have a look at it with
the engine just give me a second here
okay here we go I have the analysis
running yeah let's see what I could have
done different in the middle game
because this was a game where I felt
like it well got to a point where I
didn't I just didn't know what to do I
had all my pieces out and then it's
really lacking a plan felt like it was
easier for white to play with pushing
some pawns on the Kings side hmm and I
add the two bishops but it's not really
enough so let's see I don't think
there's any serious issue with this
initial stage you know so right around
here like there's fine clean c5 hmm okay
well points out Queen c5 Bishop here and
then Queen back to c7 now we're not
going to do that
so I castled and now yeah this is
something I want to test out what would
I do on e5 take first and then okay okay
then I could think about Bishop to c5
ideas that's what the computer
suggesting here but yeah as we could see
it's a very sharp position all theses on
board oh I didn't mean to go all the way
back okay well I just wanted and that's
my that's what I usually like to do
cover the what-ifs this is something
that had Mike and I was concerned about
e5 my phone it didn't play it so I
wanted to have a little peek at it so
Bishop c5 is an idea
rook f3 I should have I should have
really said to myself this isn't a so
much a bother anymore when Brooke f3 was
played it wants to go with Queen c5 this
is what I wanted to do but I thought
after Queen c5 Bishop to e3 what am i
doing there on Queen to b4
mmm very computer-like queen bee for
hitting b2 keeping pressure on the night
and now Knight to g4 is an idea kicking
the bishop away from defending the
knight how could I have seen this idea
better hmm
oh you know what on Queen c5 Bishop III
maybe I should have registered this move
here as a bit of a drawback for a white
in the sense that it's masking both
major pieces from seeing e5 from
supporting e5 this is really the one
move that if there's one move in the
position for white that will really
increase the possibilities if there's
one pawn move for white that would
really increase the possibilities for
the white pieces it would be e 5 has a
new square for the knight the bishop F v
g6 h7 and if the e-file is cracked open
both Queen and rook of course brought to
life so yeah
Queen c5 Bishop e3 Queen B - it's also
pointing at something that's unprotected
okay I really not to take it too much
further there this is convincing enough
for me I guess she can rely upon the B 4
square if we have a look at it how could
she be challenged from b4 I don't know
of a game that I played a standard game
not too long ago where I was saying when
the move
a4 is in that I feel a little bit more
confident about knowing where my Queen
night belongs because at some point the
knight can make use of before maybe I
can also be saying that about a queen
the B 4 squares a bit sensitive any
piece really on b4 okay a rook would be
clumsy but a knight or even a queen as
we're seeing here might take up a nice
post now that a4 is in
okay well what you're hearing right now
is me basically trying to teach myself
so yeah just making these mental notes
okay I went with g6 which felt very
funny to weaken both f6 and h6 but not
bad I guess at the end of the day
not best but not bad
King there and now night see five is
fine you know it's such a sharp position
I really should have kicked it into a
higher gear sooner you know okay any
five is a finery pie
now that wants to go with f5 doubled
first d5 I didn't like d5 because of a 5
and I didn't have this jumping point hmm
yeah this honestly I didn't like this
structural change no I didn't see Bishop
c5 that's that's kind of scary
if I go here feels like there's some
pawn sacrifice with f5 or even g4g for
f5
hmm yeah this feels a little bit iffy
because my bishop my LightSquared Bishop
and my knight are not playing I better
have something on the queenside fast
otherwise light is just a couple moves
away and this is blasted open if f5 is
in and I'm not fast on the queenside
forget about it
okay I didn't consider d5 that's that's
really a tough one to assess in a blitz
game that's transformation with the pawn
structure
unfortunately this is a bit of a passing
move wasn't quite sure what to do
King h8 rogue age 3 this is this is a
bit kind of going all-in for one if I
could somehow get to the back rank you
know there's not this flight Square
anymore with the rook on h3 but I'm
still roughly equal you're saying
Queen c5 we can see five and then night
there I think it popped up h5 for a
moment but it's fine with Queen
eighty-three and now Knight there so I
should have something here let's just go
pawn hunting oh that's tough for me to
do but why what was the move I played
King g7 alright let's consider those two
moves
grab a pond or a king to g7 so this is
another improvement I can make just what
can I say about this
there's I really can't say that my King
is any safer on g7 than h8
I think what really triggered King g7 is
getting off of the filed of rook but I
mean as we saw in the game there are
these ideas connected with f5 and the
bishop being a being able to make use of
h6 questioning my king position so in
such a complicated position I I don't
think that I could really say one way or
the other that the king is safer on h8
or g7 so maybe that was my that would be
a cue for me to know pick up a pond
maybe even then I can grab two pawns in
the center and white would still be a
little bit off-balance I could trade
Queens for example I don't know what is
it suggesting here f5 but just to make a
passing move to show something like this
might be close to happening you know
where I could get three pawns for the
piece and if I could get the Queen's off
I'd be nice okay well I didn't go
picking up upon King g7 and now I'm
worse Knight g5 h6 is fine Knight takes
pawn this isn't a correct sacrifice but
I do consider king takes okay tough to
really say
wants to play Knight to g8 instead of
pushing
hmm okay well clearly I did fine Knight
to g8 g5 and I think I'm in some trouble
yeah doesn't like g5 this right here was
to play Bishop takes h6
9 g8 could have done a better defensive
job here okay
after g5 is it gone I'm just curious
this last part about the sacrifice it
just wants to pick up on a4 is there
anything or Queen takes record I'm just
trying to be flashy here no it's not a
correct sacrifice what concerned me
still was if I'm Queen takes pawn Knight
here looking at the f5 square but I
could cover that Bishop takes pawn
mm-hmm well missed a lot of stuff for
this one let's look these final moves I
miss anything did I have anything in
this serious serious time pressure
rook check King e1 back to his home
square and yeah I mean I didn't really
want to do this but you know I guess I
don't have anything
yeah oh now I do man
yeah this is a flat-out win now what did
i do bishop c8 Bishop b4 as a win
ah man if Bishop here I take and they
have to get up the Queen and the
alternative with the computers pointing
out his knight here
but now night takes and then I'm winning
a piece around the Queen so this was a
win here with Bishop to b4 what can I do
and there's no time
tough to defend tough to find wins
although that wasn't the most difficult
move in the world it's the most forcing
move at that point yeah this is one
where if you look at the graph of the
game it'll look like a heart beat a lot
of ups and downs well no that's not a
good analogy there'll be a lot of spikes
for both sides let's say I should be
four that says there's some draw
but yeah no it's no good
okay well we got a sharp game out of the
Sicilian at least I guess I have some
draw here tricky to defend though with
Bishop to e7 wants to go with at this
point
yeah covering these entry points tough
to coordinate too too difficult and now
it's completely busted even had a
million-two here Queen takes h6 and then
queen g6 would have been a nice finish
but all the same dropping the bishop and
then the rook and it'd be made soon
enough from there anyhow
okay well one more to say
sharp game out of a Sicilian and yeah I
learned a thing or two from this one I
hope you did as well and feel free to
leave any feedback in the comment
section below as usual and I will catch
you in the next video
that's all for now take care bye
you
[Music]